[موسيقى]
هكذا يبدو مركز مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعدي الميلادي وراس السنه في وقت
تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهرها العاشر انه
قال حربي محزن للغايه او للاسف الحرب شيئا
واقع ومتكرر في الحياه التاريخ يعيد نفسه
ولا يمكن للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف فها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه الصوفيه تقف
مزينه تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل
بالوقود وفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوان
العلم الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد
رمز الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلجين الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عن ظروف الحرب
بين الطعام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه لكن
على اي حال يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد
الميلاد لان شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات
يريدون ان يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمان يحكي اياني
مفارقه كبيره الزينه والاضواء تملان كل
ارجاء المدينه لاعاده البهجه والفرح
للمواطن الروسي في ظل الاوضاع الراهنه
خاصه ان الشريط الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله
توتر وسقوط عشرات الصواريخ يوميه
لكل روسي اقرباء في اوكرانيا ونحن شعب
واحد وهذه حقيقه
للاستسلام تبحث عن ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها
اعياد الميلاد في المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام
الاختراع لذا ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه
الفكره تمام
الطاقه ده دراجه رياضيه تحول الطاقه
الحركيه الى كهرباء لتضيء شجره الميلاد
التي تزين صاله الركاب
انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره بلادنا الحره
المستقله
لاجتماع الاسره حتى ان البعض يطلق عليها
تسميتها العيد العائلي عدد من الشباب
يحتفل بغصه في الحلق هذه السنه بعيدا عن
جولها الى هرب من التعبئه والعديد من
العائلات الروسيه تستقبل عمها الجديد خارج
ديارهم التي لا طالما زقزقت فيها شمعه راس
السنه الجديده ورقصوا على انغامي تمنياتي
بالحبي والسلام بعدين كانت شوارعها سابقا
ترقص وتغني بزينه العيد ويختلط ليلها
بنارها
هي كيف تقابل اعياد الميلاد والاسر
والاكرانيه في حاله من الشتات النساء
والاطفال غادروا بلادهم والرجال منتصرون
على الجبهات والباقوله يواجهون اوضاع
الانسانيه كارثه ولسان حالهم يقول باي حال
عدت يا عيد